one we're gonna hear now from our
industry partners and their support
helps us with many aspects of our work
here at the Institute including funding
workshops and the
postdoc stipends and many other things
so thank you for all your support and
we're really happy that each of our
industry Partners has a representative
here today to tell us about their work
and speakers talks are 15 minutes and we
have Carson minding the clock here
she'll give you a five minute and a two
minute warning so that 15 minutes
includes questions in the setup time and
stuff so it's a pleasure to have
Sunshine guard with us today telling us
about zero knowledge snarks as a service
so welcome thank you yeah thanks for the
invitation I'm sanjum uh uh it's it's
really fun to be here and Simon's
representing entity so it's a pretty
pretty fun
um so I'll be talking today about zero
knowledge snark as a service what we we
call ZK SAS this is based on a joint
work with arushi who is also at NTT
Abhishek Jen who's at John Hopkins at
Guru swamship and Shruti Saker who are
at UC Berkeley okay so let me remind you
what snarks are or zero knowledge
succinct non-interactive arguments of
knowledge are it's a bit of a mouthful
so I'll go slowly over it and hopefully
by the end of it will be clear so we
have approver uh Innovative fire and the
poover wants to convince the verifier
that a certain computation C on input X
and W outputs work so that's what the
approval wants to convince the verifier
the prover gets this input X and W X is
called the statement what that's what we
call the statement and W is what we
often refer to as the witness it's sort
of the the secret input that the
approver has and the verifier only has
access to the public part of this this
which is X and the the the actual
computation we want to perform the the
circuit C or whatever other model of
computation you want is is also public
we are prover computes approved by and
sends to the verifier and the verifier
at this time either outputs accept or
reject except meaning he accepts the
prover's claim the uh the circuit or
this computation C on input X and some
value W outputs one
uh and rejects uh outputs reject if he
rejects the score okay
so in in short what this proof Pi is
supposed to be is a privacy preserving
short certificate a testing to the
correctness of this computation so let
me go over this each word here and and
kind of elaborate on what they mean and
how they relate to the nomenclature of
snarks the zero knowledge to sync
non-interactive argument technology so
the Privacy preserving part means that
the prove this this proof tie that's
sent to the verifier does not leak
information about the witness tablet in
other words the the proverb uh keeps W
hidden and that's where the zero
knowledge word comes in
the short aspect of the certificates is
um represents the succinctness in the
name which is that the time to verify
and thereby also the size of the proof
Phi the prover sensitive verifi is small
um we want you know definitely want this
proof to be uh sub-linear in the time it
takes to compute the circuit this
computation C so it should be smaller
than
um so the verifiers should have to spend
less time than the prover does uh
ideally we typically kind of want the
size of the proof and the verification
time to basically be independent of the
the computational index maybe this
computation takes you know a year but
the verifier can verify in a few
milliseconds
um we want these to be certificates so
you you know if you're familiar with
this area there are other forms of zero
knowledge proofs which involve
interaction here we want these to be
certificates where the prover once
issues this proof to the verifier the
verifier can go around give this uh
certificate to others and they would
also be equally convinced that the
statement that this computation was done
correctly okay
okay and the final thing is uh this
proof attests to this uh the correctness
of this computation uh in particular a
cheating prover a malicious Brewer
cannot convince a verifier that a
statement is is true in particular it
cannot make a verifier output except if
the statement is actually closed if
there does not exist a value W such that
the circuit c x on any in all possible
inputs outputs zero then the the
verifier will not accept uh
will not accept this proof and and you
know I'm kind of cheating here that the
property is a bit stronger it's not just
an argument but argument of knowledge in
fact the proof certifies that not only
that there exists this value W but in
fact the prover knows it okay so this is
what
um zero knowledge succinct
non-interactive arguments of knowledge
are and you know they've been immensely
you know we've been studying them for
over you know uh since 92 so a fair bit
of time
um but you know they have kind of really
in the last decade uh become of
significant interest and you know
tremendous amount of applications
I'll just describe at a high level uh a
few a very important ones the first one
actually goes back to uh a vision from
from David Chum in in the 80s where he
talked about Anonymous credentials think
about going to a liquor store and
proving to the cashier that you're above
18 uh without disclosing to them your
name and date of birth which is uh
typically written on your driver's
license in which you typically do [ __ ]
so that sort of uh the digital analog is
anonymous credentials uh zika snars make
this you know there are other ways to do
it but DK snars also enables some of
these applications
um privacy preserving crypto so you want
you know if you've heard about the the
sort of no privacy on on bitcoin if you
make any transactions if I send you ten
dollars
um then they can effectively be traced
um we can use zika snarks to add privacy
uh at least to some extent for example Z
cash does
in the same way we have private smart
contracts which allow for executing
smart contracts on things like ethereum
uh in in a in a privacy preserving way
and finally
um sort of a very cool application which
is not related to cryptocurrency is it
sort of fight in fighting disinformation
so for example uh let's say there's a
picture taken in uh Ukraine by a
particular camera and the camera
generates the picture with the signature
that this um image was taken uh at a
particular latitude and longitude uh
using the GPS information it has access
to you can take that picture and give a
proof that was taken somewhere in
Ukraine without leaking exactly where it
was so you could sort of attach a ZK
snog that allows you to do that so
um in an effort to fight this
information and you know these are some
example applications
um but they're sort of now already
multi-billion dollar companies which are
trying to kind of commercialize on uh ZK
snarge or Associated Technologies
um the techniques that are developed so
this is sort of uh really uh um you know
growing very rapidly
and by the way this is just like a I put
three examples the the many of these
companies okay so uh you know what is
sort of the main you know the sort of a
lot of research that has gone in over
the last decade we've seen tremendous
improvements but still the key
bottleneck in using these like you know
completely ubiquitously is uh blueberry
on times so if the original computation
that you you know Iran let's say in time
T if you wanted to generate a ZK snark
for that it would take roughly 250 to
500 times the time to generate the proof
and this is this is quite expensive and
you know I'm not talking about all
circuits of the typical circuit that
people are using and the numbers we we
see and this overhead becomes uh even
bigger when we're talking about as the
size of the computations becomes larger
so this is not sort of linear factorism
and part of the reason is as uh the size
of the computations become larger the
memory overheads become larger you have
to keep all this large amount of
information in memory and their page
faults and and so on which pushes uh
proof times to be even larger
so our goal has been to kind of you know
and this is sort of for the community as
well there are a lot of people working
on the school in trying to generate
proofs or realize proof systems which
will prove faster okay and you know
there are many many techniques uh we uh
discussed there the specific uh path
that we will try here is can we use uh
software as a solution to generate these
snarks faster so can I Outsource the
computation to someone else
um to do it and you can imagine like you
know maybe trying to generate a zika
snark on your phone I'm sending you 10
bucks I want to generate a proof for
that they'll go on some blockchain
application and you want to kind of post
that on the blockchain and you want to
generate this proof quickly okay so a
very nice work that tries to sort of in
a similar way and do this as the the
design work what this work does is that
I'm trying to generate a snog okay I'm
computationally constrained why not let
me go out and hire a cluster of
computers that will do it faster for me
this is exactly what this work does and
they they're able to achieve tremendous
efficiency gains as you would expect and
and part of the reason is that you know
these smart computations are often
highly parallelizable so you can kind of
distribute the work in a cluster
but one key problem is that you
compromise on privacy so if I go to AWS
and I'm hiring 10 machines to generate
my ZK snort I have to give hand over my
witness to them right so this could
include the secrets for my uh you know
Bitcoin or ethereum wallet and you know
uh that that's a a problem okay so on
the other side of the coin there is uh a
different work it's called collaborative
ZK snark
um what this work tries to do is it
tries to generate ZK snark where the
witness originally that I'm trying to
generate the start with was distributed
across untrusting uh machines okay so it
kind of goes on the other side it says
look I have uh 10 machines they hold uh
secret shares uh or like sort of shares
which themselves don't reveal the
witness but collectively can be used to
generate the the snark and and this work
uh shows how we can generate snarks on
this side
but the problem in this case is that the
cost of generating the snarg per or the
amount of work that each server has to
do grows is is exactly the same as what
it would take to run the same
computation on a local machine yeah
yeah so this one does not uh no privacy
give the witness someone else is doing
it but tomorrow is the same in terms of
trust
the distributed customer here
everybody's trusted here you know think
about honest majority oh I see so
they're trusted okay there's there's no
no everybody's complicated
yeah just efficiency this one there's
some trust
um also both as efficiency but the
efficiency you get is look if I it took
me one second to generate it on my
system
um you know because I have a small
machine I'm going to hire you know a
bigger machine somewhere which can run a
secure computation protocol to generate
it uh but you know the work done by each
machine is going to be one set like it's
going to take one second it's going to
be the same work as I would have done
okay those are these cases there's some
ways in some place and then you give it
to pieces or did they get or they
generated already in this good so in
this case
um you know you have the witness and you
give them and there's no privacy could
uh in this case they're assuming that
the witness is already distribute
great so uh great questions thank you um
you know in this case the cost of each
device is the same as the cost per
generating proof on a uh with a
singleution
uh when we you know a natural approach
to do it is like you know maybe I want
to kind of mix the two together and
rather than having one machine you know
doing sort of this secure computational
collaborative scenario between machines
rather we do a collaborative snark
between clusters of machine then we can
perhaps you know get efficiency from
using music uh but sort of this privacy
guarantees we want from from this work
the challenge you know one aspect that
is is not appealing from a zika SAS
perspective is that we're going to have
high monetary costs right so if you
imagine having a distributed network of
64 kind of uh a a clusters of machines
and each cluster having 50 machines I'm
paying the cost of you know 64 times
what it would have taken in Disney
so what we want is we can't sort of
better monetary costs so we want faster
proof times while keeping you know while
Distributing the proof by getting like
division of labor so as I am generating
the snark over 64 machines let's say
which we're going to do in this work uh
I want some division of labor such that
each machine does you know doesn't do
work proportional to the cost of
generating the smart local
so here's our framework
um what we're going to do is we're going
to have approver who has an input X and
W it's going to go to the Google cloud
or Amazon and say please give me access
to one large machine this is a machine
that has some you know larger
computational resources but more
importantly larger uh memory and it's
because you're going to ask for uh
off-the-shelf commodity hardware for you
know several other machines so think
about one large device or more powerful
device and 63 smaller devices
um there's going to be some
pre-processing let's let's ignore that
uh the prover is going to sort of secret
share its witness among these um devices
and this step is typically not not
expensive and subsequently these servers
are going to interact and pop out will
come the ZK snarb
and the Key Properties we want is that
the amount of computational effort spent
by each of these machines roughly grows
with one by n or tilde of one by n of
what the work would have been on a
single machine
okay so effectively I'm dividing the
work among these machines as this
computation happens so thereby I am
going to get efficient faster proof
times because everybody's has to do less
work I've uh and and that effectively
that work is happening in parallel
um but because I have uh um n machines
now and you know the the factor is one
by n the overall memory blow up in the
overall computational cost plot is only
order one okay so I'm paying order one
uh in uh my cost but I'm getting uh one
by n in uh uh you know the reduction in
in running time yes
well I mean I'm I'm looking at the
higher order terms
um
yeah so
um you know when the work is very small
and this is an approximation right so if
you're doing
um uh I'm looking at very large amount
of work and N being not very large so
maybe there is sort of some discrepancy
it doesn't have to be exactly uh
identical for every server it's just
roughly the same it makes sense
so yeah
thank you good and the security
um in our setting will hold as long as
less than and by four of the parties
so this is our model
um in this work uh since I'm running
more time I'll quickly summarize the
work so we construct new ZK SAS
protocols for sure many popular
um ZK snares so you can take uh popular
zika snarts such as grot modeling Planck
growth and plunk being very widely used
in in out there
um and you can fit in the ZK ZK SAS
framework and get a uh a protocol to do
so you know snark as a software as a
service
um and we implemented the grot16 version
for
grot16 DK snark we're able to reduce
prover Time by roughly an order of a
magnitude okay so and it kind of depends
on the constraint size and the many
other things but it's almost always
better than an order of magnitude
um the sort of two key challenges here
you know effectively uh for the the ones
for you know for the cryptographers in
the crowd you know we want to do like an
NPC to do a ZK snark so there are two
main challenges one is you know it's not
cryptographic operations if you're going
to open them up as circuits it's going
to blow up the cost so that's sort of
one challenge the second is how are we
going to actually get this division of
labor if so there's some computation we
need to kind of divide it and for the
first one we're going to roughly do like
an MPC uh in the exponent so we can pull
out the cryptographic operations outside
the NPC and the second
um for the second idea we observed that
for these snark and many other snarks we
looked very closely at these ones but
for for other snarkets as well you can
take the actual algorithm for generating
the snark and split it into sort of
three key components phosphoria
transforms multi-scalar multiplication
and sum of partial products and what
we're able to show is we're uh uh sort
of custom protocols that are constant
around low communication costs and all
this nice features such that we can get
division of labor so this division of
labor then translates to a solution for
uh snacks thank you
[Applause]
speaker is
from Google and